sarah mais en 2019 vous avait enflammé
les plaines d'abraham lors du spectacle
de la fête nationale du québec
là vous remettez sur cette année mais
s'arrête en mode virtuel pour vous de
participer à la fête nationale qu'est ce
que ça signifie
mais c'est sûr que c'est une fête qui a
toujours fait partie de ma vie que j'ai
beaucoup fêté dans mes années de cégep
quand j'habitais à québec donc c'est
vraiment un honneur c'est la même équipe
qui produit chaud cette année ils
meurent fait confiance et je trouve
aussi qu'il font confiance aux
aujourd'hui que je fais au rapt en ce
qui concerne tout ce qu'on aime tous les
bus pour la petite histoire vous êtes né
en 1986 au sénégal votre frère c'est
karim wallet vous avez été adopté par un
couple de québécois
votre père était diplomate et là vous
avez une toute nouvelle chanson
aujourd'hui
bienvenue dans ma vie
deux pages et cela sur deux arrive en
ville où vous rendez hommage à votre
mère carole audet oui voilà pourquoi cet
âge maintenant parce que souvent quand
on demande la musique il ya d'où je
parle tous vos souvent de bons mais
référencera français mon père qui nous
faisait écouter du reggae puis souvent
je mets ma mère est un bluff le
souligner et puis à la raison parce que
elle a joué on a toujours écouter sa
musique à la maison
elle était avec des musiciens
traditionnels il pratiquait ils ont fait
ma mère a fait beaucoup de spectacles
aussi à la maison des concerts privés
elles avaient des amis que jouer du
piano classée qu'elle est jouée de la
kora qui est cet instrument à cordes
l'afrique de l'ouest est ce un clin
d'oeil à notre histoire avec l'afrique
notre histoire familiale finalement et
voilà c'était son moment
ajouté
vous utilisez le rap américain mélangé
avec certaines sonorités africaines dans
la pièce ma peau qui soit votre deuxième
album vous dit
ma pauvre de moi ce que je suis elle ne
disparaît pas sur la pluie en 12 v ce
besoin de revendiquer vos identités
multiples je pense c'est venu avec le
temps ça vient avec l'âge la maturité
mais ça vient aussi avec les expériences
de vie je pense que je suis confronté à
on confronte à ma couleur souvent je
suis comme je dis je suis noir tous les
jours et c'est parfait comme ça et mais
ça vient avec des choses plus négative
et donc je sens le besoin d'en parler je
sens que j'ai une plateforme aussi où je
peux parler de ces sujets là autant sur
le plu sexisme le racisme chez des
sujets qui me touchent de près j'ai
besoin de dire des choses puis si je le
faisais peur je sentirais que je passe à
côté de quelque chose chez relic pas à
toi mais qu'à cela tient une photo trop
portés comme dumontier la base amène la
trace et comment la langue parce que
vous êtes assez active sur les réseaux
sociaux
vous affichez votre relation de couple
par exemple dans vos chansons vous êtes
assez cru assez direct vous savez on vit
dans une époque assez polarisée oui pas
voulu de moi bateau parfois en fait
j'essaye de protéger ce qui le plus
précieux pour moi c'est à dire que je
monte certaines choses mais je ne monte
pas tout parce que je sais que ça c'est
ma bulle et si je reçois des
commentaires négatifs aussi je me sens
je me fais attaquer sur certaines choses
ça va venir vraiment me chercher puis je
veux pas les leurs et je vais pas comme
mes proches soient blessés par des
choses donc même parfois des sujets
parfois je mettais sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est pas un endroit
pour débattre les réseaux sociaux c'est
un endroit qui polarise c'est tout ce
que ça fait écoutez du parc du pointeau
personnes
mais je me suis fait comme mot d'ordre
de toujours le dénoncer quand il se
passe quelque chose que ce que je sois
devant un interlocuteur au cauchois
témoin quelque chose je le dis quand
c'est pas vrai que je le dis puis c'est
comme ça que je peux faire ma petite
part parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
que j'ai aussi laissé passer dans ma vie
que je me suis dit que je ne serai plus
jamais passé
derrière vos vidéos clips de dur à cuire
de rappeuse une amoureuse des lettres
des boues vous avez fait des études à
l'université montréal en littérature way
est une grande lectrice à rennes je
l'étais prendre mon bac parce que
j'avais pas le choix on avait cinq à six
livres parcours à lire mais j'ai
découvert ce que j'aime et j'ai
découvert des auteurs de la francophonie
j'ai découvert une histoire aussi de
l'afrique puis la francophonie que je
connaissais pas à travers ces études là
et c'est resté avec moi j'ai appris ça
sur le tard je trouve
et j'ai trouvé ça dommage
d'apprentissage sur le tard mais j'étais
contente donc oui là j'aime lire je sais
ce que j'aime lire je suis plus vu que
c'est moins poser maintenant j'ai plus
de plaisir à lire vous inspire à écrire
des chansons je me gêne parce que plus
haut lui plus c'est facile de manier le
verbe exactement ça va avec je lis je
lis des choses qui me pousse à réfléchir
je suis plus dans les lectures
philosophiques
de spiritualité j'aime beaucoup ça ouais
je trouve que ça fait grandir l'âme que
ça que ça ouvre l'esprit
ouais je vais des mois ouais ouais ouais
c'est ce que j'aime lire parce que je
lis je viens de finir un paulo coelho la
voix de l'arche est un classique que
j'avais pas lu mais qui se lit tellement
bien et chaque page comme moi ouais
ouais moi j'aime ça va ramer merci pour
cette belle rancourt merci merci merci
merci
[Musique]
doha